au coeur du village de flavigny sur
ozerain la maison des arts textiles et
du design invite à une plongée dans
l'histoire du textile bourguignon un
riche passé
tombé dans l'oubli qui se souvient que
pendant des siècles le chanvre a été
cultivé filets tissés par les paysans et
artisans
c'est une culture qui a été extrêmement
importante jusqu'au 19ème siècle on en a
fait régulièrement et un peu partout ici
nous avions tous l'eau les tisserands
les ateliers et une matière formidable
je veux savoir que foires de champagne
le chanvre bourguignon était le meilleur
c'était celui qui était vendue en
premier les cordages était fait en
chanvre enfin le chanvre était
omniprésent dans la société d'alors et
c'était une économie florissante dans
les collections du musée ce noeud de
haubans une pièce unique
la fibre de chanvre dont la solidité
était incomparable a été très utilisé
dans la marine les voiles des bateaux
fabriqués en bourgogne était parmi les
meilleurs
une toile très apprécié pour le linge de
maison
ce sont les torchons inusable de nos
grands-mères donc ce torchon est un
torchon de chambre du 19e siècle qui a
été bien des bouillies et qui est d'une
douceur remarquable ce tissu à chevrons
c'est du chanvre le pantalon de treillis
d'un infirmier de la guerre de 14-18 des
vêtements de la passementerie de la
dentelle un fils et une matière tout
aussi indispensable autrefois que la
laine le musée rend hommage à louis jean
marie daubenton grand ami de buffon qui
ont 1777 a importé d'espagne des moutons
pour les acclimater au bourgogne est
lancée l'élevage du mérinos précoce dans
le châtillonnais
il a fait un travail remarquable alors
bourguignon à 100% prenne mon bar au
prieuré de cours tangi pendant des
années
on était mené des expériences justement
des sélections très naturel sur des
différentes troupes de moutons pour
faire une laine extraordinaire cette
broderie en fils de soie date du xviiie
siècle fait par des religieuses c'est
une véritable oeuvre d'art
aucun ne apparent temps au recto et au
verso le travail de la soie dès le 14e
siècle en bourgogne il n'a pas pu
rivaliser avec les soyeux lyonnais
relancer au 19e siècle
en voici l'une des rares pièces
sauvegarder au musée c'est un brassard
de communiants les teintures naturelles
et on voit toute l'élégance de ceux de
cette broderie bourguignonne encore au
19e siècle oui c'est une pièce que nous
sommes heureux de pouvoir exposer ses
portraits photographiques un tissage
jacquard en soi a inspiré daniel al
granat le fondateur du musée
fasciné par léonard de vinci dont il a
réalisé le visage en trois variations
sur le métier à tisser dalle granat
décédé en 2013 un échantillon peut être
pour cardin ou courrèges avec qui il
travaillait designer international
ancien élève de l'école boulle son musée
à vocation de valoriser l'art textile
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
je souhaite que ce lieu veille sur le
patrimoine et en même temps l'ouvrir à
des artistes contemporains pour qu'il y
ait cette évolution naturelle d'un lieu
vivant et par exemple christophe allegri
qui est tailleur de pierre qui vit en
bourgogne
quelqu'un qui a déjà fait des sculptures
que j'expose et daniel stéphane et à
très généreusement donné pour les
collections du musée plusieurs avant
enfin une vaste bibliothèque complète
l'espace muséographique 1600 livres
parmi lesquels des ouvrages rares comme
ce livre de fabrique qui ressemble à une
partition musicale
c'est l'adn des étoffes la mémoire des
techniques des tisserands bourguignon